[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
guess who's back guess who's back guess
who's back that's right I'm back
[Music]
and holy [__] there's a ton of news that
is built up just just since I've been
gone getting some sun thank you very
much for staying tuned
and and and making sure that Gabe
Sanchez as the guest host had plenty of
support I think he's going to join us
today of course he is he'll join us
today thank you for for staying with us
as I took a few days off to get some sun
I did I I hung up by the pool I hung
hung out by the lake it was much needed
reprieve I appreciate the audience here
and I appreciate all your kind words and
I appreciate you guys uh all your kind
words to Gabe did a main a magnificent
job while I was gone yesterday I popped
in my shades on still
there's a lot of news
Chris Christie tries to throw a punch
doesn't he
towards the crimes that Donald Trump has
committed
speaking of crimes do you think Mark
Meadow is flipping well I mean there's
only there's only three options here
right like you can narrow it down what
Mark Meadows is doing is either he full
on has negotiated an immunity deal which
would not surprise me that Mark Meadows
that treasonous piece of [__] was turn
his loyalty against Trump negotiate a
immunity deal I mean there's that
there's also that he's being forced to
testify
so that way he doesn't make himself a
huge Target
and then he could plea the fifth as well
like you know there's there's only so
many options that Mark Meadows has here
but the big question is is he flipping
on Trump
and with immunity I mean that's really
the the question
are these people who are testifying
against Donald Trump in front of the
grand jury speaking of that
a trump aide who works for one of his
super Pacs was spotted going into
another grand jury
Miami
he does Christ
I I think I think Donald Trump is going
to set the record
and for how many criminal grand juries a
former president has had convened
for the crimes that he has committed
he'll probably hold that record for a
long time too
I think like literally I think that's I
think he already holds the record
he's the most criminal president in the
history that we've ever had
and the most criminal ex-president that
we've ever had
we watched Chris Christie throw some
punches oh my god listen
there is gonna be
there is going to be a ton of appetite
for Chris Christie to keep pounding on
Trump but did you notice how it fell
flat
he goes after Trump he goes after Ivanka
and Jared nothing
Trump's like oh he's fat and it's
and moglodytes are like yeah Chris
Christie's fat have you seen Grandpa
lately
guys not the [__]
Picture Perfect of skinny okay our fit
for that matter Jesus Christ he's
[__] humongous
you kidding me dude
fat dude is calling another dude fat and
it worked it [__] worked he totally
totally deflated the Krispy Kreme Chris
Christie
and one Fell Swoop with one little video
making fun of his
habit of eating
but Chris Christie threw some punches
you know what I mean I told you Chris
Christie would I told you this when
Chris Christie finally got in he would
punch on Donald Trump
it's just a matter if they're Landing
these punches now
I expect Chris Christie to do more
jabbing at Trump he's going to keep
jabbing and jabbing jabbing that Ron
DeSantis is too weak and too cowardly to
do by the way
I don't know if you know this Chris
Christie is a former prosecutor did you
know did you know that Chris Christie
asks a former prosecutor as a former
United States Attorney put Jared
kushner's dad in prison did you know
that
that [__] that he did
but let me let me let me tell you
something about Chris Christie's
campaign and the reason why it will fail
here
same reason why Mike Pence he's
announcing this morning
hang Mike Pence said no Pence voter ever
what they wanted to hang you dude they
don't want you to be their president
get get the [__] over it it's about as
far as I'm gonna have to go with Mike
Pence we might watch a little bit of the
stupid [__] hand that he cut about
how he wants God he wants God to be at
the Forefront of our country again as if
Americans have an appetite for religion
the [__] out of here we've had enough of
your religion to be quite honest
foreign
as a United States Attorney put Jared
kushner's dad in prison
now this has always been a source of
tension I'm sure
in Trump Kushner Ivanka Christie's
relationship you remember Chris Christie
was a big advocate for him in the 2016
campaign
and then when it came to the
administration ah Chris Christie was cut
out because Chris Christie put Jared's
dad in prison so he just he wasn't
welcome in the administration
and he kind of got a little sour over
this now
in 2020 Chris Christie damn near died
trying to prep Donald Trump
for debate when he caught covet from
Trump
because they weren't practicing
protocols damn near killed the guy damn
near kill that [__] had to go to
the hospital for days weeks I think I
don't know I don't know
Kobe didn't do its job I guess I don't
know but the point is this
there's only one question that Chris
Christie has to answer if he wants to
garnish votes
anywhere really for that matter there's
only one question that Chris Christie
needs to be asked and he needs answer
after that he can just go sit on the
beach somewhere
by himself or with his family what you
know whatever he's into
the question that Chris Christie needs
to be asked and the only question that
he needs to answer really answer not
[__] skirt around it
and act like he'd give a non-answer you
know what I mean typical Chris Christie
type [__] he really needs to answer this
if what you say about Trump is true if
everything you say about him is true and
you truly believe this [__] and you're
saying about him which Chris Christie
sounds authentic when he punches and
Jabs at Trump
you know I I think most Republicans know
that the guy is a [__] idiot
Trump that is
they know he's derelict in his duty they
know he's a treasonous piece of [__]
they know he's an egotistical lunatic
yeah most most folks know that even his
most Avid supporters
know that he's a [__] wackadoo
but the question that you have to ask
Chris Christie is why why knowing all
that and saying this out loud because
that's why Ron DeSantis won't say it you
know that right the reason why Rhonda
Santos won't attack Donald Trump like
Chris Christie is because Rhonda santis
can't handle the question that Chris
Christie needs to answer
the question is this
if you believe all that stuff about
Trump
if all these attacks on Trump are true
then why why did you support him in 2016
why did you continue to support him
through his presidency and why did you
help this egomaniac this megalomaniac
this dictator wannabe
in debate prep to try to beat Joe Biden
and try to get power hmm
I know the answer to the question
I know the answer Chris Christie
wouldn't give this answer but this is
the [__] answer
that is the truth Chris Christie wants
power Chris Christie wants to be close
to power
that's what he wants he wants he wanted
to be in the administration in the first
place in 2016. he wanted to be a part of
the 2020 race so that he could be in the
second terms Administration so he had
some sort of lever of power
because that's what it is to these
[__] fascists
that's what it is to these [__] Nazi
Republicans
it's all about their own [__] power
they don't care about the American
people if Chris Christie really gave a
[__] about the American people do you
really think that he was supported a guy
of the [__] that he's saying now get the
[__] out of here with that nonsense and
it ain't just politics folks
the guy trying to overturn the
government of the United States
he was planning on making sure that if
he lost he wouldn't he would not lose
his office no matter what Chris Christie
had to know this he was he was debate
prepping him
he caught covet damn near died for
Donald Trump
now Chris Christie will never answer
this question
he'll never give the truth
that's why Chris Christie was so willing
to cuddle up to Donald Trump for power
it's a reason why Rhonda Santos did it
Rhonda santis went so far out of his way
he gained weight changed his hair mocked
mocked Trump's movements
he was a parrot to his speech
and his language
he he he bought new suits to look like
Trump
have you noticed that Rhonda Santos
doesn't wear the Trump drag anymore
I mean where's the high heels the
high-heeled boots you know because you
know
he's got he's got this little syndrome
right
where you don't want people know he's
got a little dick
you know these guys who drive these big
trucks or the big tires the big Trump
Flags don't haul [__] in the back of the
truck never had never will
same thing same [__]
but again Ron DeSantis will not
put on the gloves like Chris Christie
will because Rhonda Santos does not want
to answer that question because guess
what
the answer to the question of Rhonda
Santos of why did he placate to Donald
Trump why
did he suckle at the teat of trumpism
and Maca
why did he continue to go down the road
of fascism and bigotry
why does he have the woke mind virus
because Rhonda Santos definitely has the
woke mind writers I don't know if you've
seen him Jesus Christ the guy can't stop
saying the word woke
it's insane
I've never seen someone with such a hard
disease in my life
Ron DeSantis but the reason why Rhonda
santis won't punch at Trump like Chris
Christie will is because Ron DeSantis
isn't as good of a retail politician as
Chris Christie is
that's this that's that's just the truth
Rhonda Santos is a fascist [__] robot
in a human skin suit
and he's awkward as [__] Chris Christie
is a damn good retail politician he just
is that's why he did it in a town hall
setting in New Hampshire not on [__]
Twitter with Elon Musk another [__]
Android in a skin suit a fascist Android
and a skin suit
so yeah Chris Christie is a better
retail politician
but it it's not gonna work
it's not
it's a cult man
I'm talking to Chris here Chris listen
man it's a cult it's a [__] cult and
you're not you're not gonna you're not
gonna wedge down in the cult punching on
Donald I mean I don't want you to stop
man don't don't get me wrong don't stop
keep punching at him oh my God the ABS
the ads that we're gonna get to run with
you
[__] punching down on Donald Trump in
the general election while you support
the nominee Donald Trump is gonna be
[__] ah fantastic
they're all going to support this
[__]
even Mark Meadows who's flipping on him
now will probably be out in public like
yeah I'm voting for Donald Trump what
you're dude you're
you're flipping on him
Chris Christie's gonna support him Ron
DeSantis is gonna support him Bill Barr
that's right [__] Bill Barr I'm
gonna show you a clip today this is a
great oh this is Juicy this is delicious
[__] delicious
Bill Barr is certain that Donald Trump
is going to be indicted certain of it
because in his words he jerked them
around the doj
and he says this is a [__]
personality pattern of this the Cheeto
dusk unit on her Grandpa booby pants
that's what Bill Bart says these are not
my words these are Bill Barr's words
we're gonna use all this folks I don't
know if if you're if you're just tuning
in right if you're just paying attention
to the politics now in our country and
the election cycle that we're about to
enter which is the Republican primary
boy are you gonna miss a sh have you
been missing the show
but it's gonna be a hell of a show it's
gonna be a great trumpster fire this
summer and this fall leading up to the
primaries are you kidding me it's gonna
be fantastic
we're gonna watch these Republicans rip
each other [__] apart just like they
did
just like they did yesterday in the
house did you see this oh my God
so I wake up yesterday morning maybe a
bit hungover maybe not with a little bit
too much sun but I woke up I opened my
phone and here are the Republicans
touting the no woke stoves Act
I don't know what they called it
something make compliances great again I
think is what uh one representative
called it I forget what they exactly
called it I called it the no Oak snows
act and really I said if they would have
named it the no Oaks dozek it would have
been much better because by yesterday
afternoon they would have had a bunch of
moglodytes with their AR-15s shooting up
electric ranges that are going to turn
you gay
I'm I'm not kidding you
I'm not I almost bet we're gonna see a
video sometime in the next few weeks
over this debacle over this gas stoves
thing
that's gonna have some [__]
right-wing influencer using an AR-15 to
shoot up a gay stove
because electric stoves make you gay or
some [__] who knows they're making up
all kinds of [__] did you hear Christy
gnome this morning on Fox News the
governor
of South Dakota Christy gnome that
[__] bigot she says she says targets
Pride display is gonna make our country
crumble in the ashes or some [__] what
the [__] are you talking about so you're
telling me you're telling me all this
time with our constitutional Democratic
Republic all the [__] we've been through
all the [__] we've been through in this
country slavery the wars the whole nine
yards civil rights
and you're telling me that a little
seasonal display for one month where it
has rainbows in it is gonna be the
downfall of our country let me tell you
something folks this is why they're
gonna [__] lose
and you better be loud and you better
keep being loud about this
Americans aren't gonna buy this line of
[__] think about this this is their
policies this is their yesterday the
House of Representatives couldn't even
vote on the rules it's been like 21
years since they couldn't pass rules
of debate of a bill on the floor of the
house not the bill itself they couldn't
even pass the rules of debate to get it
to the floor
they [__] suck at governing they're
horrible at it and it's not just in the
House of Representatives it's in [__]
States all around the nation
where they're they're horrible at this I
mean you watched it the the disaster in
Tennessee as the Republicans
ousted two black men and pulled a
mulligan on the white woman for being
loud
for being loud
they removed them and expelled them
duly elected officials in Tennessee
because they were black men
and the backlash was horrible for
Cameron Sexton
the Speaker of the House in Tennessee
and it needs to continue to be horrible
if you want to know the honest truth
these people are [__] boneheads
and their best policy the best policies
they got
is Hunter Biden dick pics
gas stoves
and Target
they're still yammering on about Bud
Light if any as if anyone gives a two
shits about Bud Light anymore
folks this is their policy platform I'm
not kidding you they are going I almost
bet
at the Republican National Convention
next next summer
they are going to be gives giving
speeches
on the on the stage about targets Pride
display
about rainbows
and how they got to get rid of rainbows
what
all the while they're just they're
trying to destroy public education in
Oklahoma
yes there's a ton of news there's a ton
of news and I can't help but
spot check every single one of these
things and we'll spend a couple days
since I've been on air a lot of shit's
happened Oklahoma decides that they're
going to give public funds taxpayer
dollars
to a religious school Charter School
guess what folks do it
do it keep going you dumb [__]
we see you for who you are and what you
are
let them keep going do not take the
shovel out of their hands when they're
digging their political grave
don't do it
that's like CNN oh here we go uh I'm
gonna go off on CNN I ain't got no
[__] time today to be quite honest
with all the [__] I gotta talk about
Chris Licht Chris licked his balls
oh he's a he's a media Darling by the
way
did you know this oh they [__] love
this guy don't get this Twisted you know
us average folks out here in America
like [__] that guy all the people who
are in media love that guy
Joe Scarborough this morning I listened
to the [__] Joe Scarborough this
morning was like oh Chris licked I'm
gonna lick his balls he's so good he'll
be back he'll be back he just made one
mistake
do you remember this
do you remember the mistake he made
we talked about it I I had a different
view than almost anyone else I said [__]
him what CNN had Trump on it'll show who
CNN truly is
it'll show Trump for who he truly is and
it did just that and now this morning
people are Oh yay Chris slick is gone at
CNN yeah yeah
what these [__] show us who
they are
why are you so scared of the truth why
is the media so scared of the truth
the reason why we're in the situation
we're in is because the media is garbage
all of them every [__] last one of
them and the reason why is because the
media is so concerned about either not
being biased or being too damn careful
so they don't get canceled or some
stupid [__] like that
that's why they don't [__] like me
mainstream doesn't like me because I
curse too much because I say things that
people are thinking and don't want to
say well [__] that [__] people don't
want to get handed their news too
carefully
stop being so goddamn careful for crying
out loud [__] tell the truth just say
the truth no one no one wants your
[__] data no one wants your [__]
polls No One Believes that [__] anyways
the polls are garbage and even if they
aren't garbage No One Believes them they
don't they don't
show me show me 5 000 Americans give me
a list of 5 000 Americans who believe
polls
they don't because they don't take them
so they don't know where they come from
they don't [__] it and they suck they
never tell us the [__] truth anyways
stop feeding us poles stop feeding this
[__] stop telling us what we can and
can't [__] do
stop telling us what we can and can't
say stop telling us what we shouldn't
shouldn't think Jesus Christ on MSNBC
for the last [__] two months Donald
Trump was going to be indicted by Jack
Smith next week next week next week next
week Nick these are supposed to be legal
analysts you're supposed to be the
[__] experts these are supposed to be
the people who know what the [__]
they're talking about
convincing people on TV that Donald
Trump next week next week oh this week
uh by the end of this week next week
Texas Paul even said it yesterday I
corrected him a bit
and I I apologize for being so abrasive
about this listen he'll be indicted when
he gets indicted
he'll be indicted when he gets indicted
by Jack Smith
Bonnie Wilson Georgia the same way
just stick your seat belt on and go
along for the ride
stop trying to control what what is
actually happening
control what you can control which is
the narrative
it's so ridiculous that the media is so
careful they finally got rid of Chuck
Todd on Meet the Press right yeah NBC
said no no more Chuck Todd so so they
put someone just as [__] bad
you don't think she's gonna just placate
to these [__] when they come on
let me tell you something Twitter resist
Twitter is gonna hate her just as they
hated Chuck Todd Garen damn Tia hide and
[__] watch hide and watch because it
ain't Chuck Todd folks
it ain't Chris Licht folks it ain't Joe
Scarborough folks it's because they're
too goddamn careful
they're too goddamn careful
American people ain't got time for you
to be careful about the news they don't
have time for that [__] think about the
world we live in how much information we
have with the internet and it's [__]
social media think about all the just
the waterfall of [__] that gets
dumped on us as we scroll down our feed
most of it not even relevant to hella
beans what we're doing on the day-to-day
and you think people are concerned about
every [__] little thing they they
hear that they're gonna go [__] look
up polls and look up data and oh man I
better Google that no they're not
they're not
they're not gonna do it they don't have
time for your [__]
just tell them what the [__] is going on
just say it and say it the way that they
would say it talk to them not Adam
media
CNN MSNBC whoever the [__] it is I don't
care who it is a lot of people gave me
heat oh man I can't believe you went
after Don Lemon Don lemon's garbage so
is Jake Tapper so is Anderson Cooper Joe
Scarborough Mika the same way
they placate they placate to the
teleprompter they beat too goddamn
careful
it's the reason why no one likes that
[__]
Anderson Cooper
I don't know if he's gonna be drunk or
not but apparently he's gonna moderate
Chris Christie's town hall on CNN
and we're standing around wondering why
we're standing around wondering why
Trump loses his mind on true social
every day are you kidding me
are you kidding me
we can't even get serious people to talk
about serious [__] in a way that people
just want to hear it
we don't we can't
it's not possible in the media
well you know there's there is some
[__] regulation in what you can and
can't say
but is there
is there really
do we need to worry so much about being
correct
about being absolutely 100 correct
people are tired tired
of people
who who aren't average Americans telling
average Americans how to be average
Americans and what average Americans
need to know
just a plane cold hard facts
don't blame me
I'm just [__] pointing it out to you
and you wonder why trumpism and why Maga
caught on in this country
are you wondering why still
are you wondering why Mark Meadows is
flipping probably going to be the key
point
of Donald Trump's Federal indictment
where he's probably going to receive a
huge prison sentence for what seems to
be possible Espionage I don't know it
looks like it could go that way done it
to you he stole documents even billboard
I'm going to show you the clip saying he
jerked him around well why was he
jerking them around why what was he
doing with this [__]
what was he doing with it
huh
you don't think he was [__] selling
it he sells everything else good God he
griffs everything you don't think him
stealing documents from the United
States government from us wasn't a grift
come on man the [__] out of here
the American people are dumb but they're
not that [__] stupid
they can see what's going on man
come on give me a [__] break
and the media is going hard man we're
not we're still not sure why why people
are supporting Trump and why Trump seems
to be winning the primary already
I'm not surprised I told you in January
really I think the end of the year I
don't know I need to go back and
re-watch when's the first time I said
Donald Trump is going to be the nominee
in 2024.
you go back and check that out figure
out what day exactly maybe I'll cut the
clip if I can find it
there's a lot of there's a lot of [__]
of me talking right
but I've been saying it since at least
the beginning of January that he was
going to be the nominee I've seen it
clearly there's no one that can contest
him no one no one no one
is going to beat him I mean other than
you know their their [__] Fail-Safe
where he chokes on a [__] Big Mac
and he's gone before he hits the ground
that's it that's their only savior here
that's it it ain't Ron DeSantis it sure
is how I [__] Mike Pence it ain't
Mark Meadows listen listen to me I know
everyone's so excited about him being
indicted and Mark Meadows flipping yay
it's not gonna stop him from being the
nominee
it's not it won't
it's a [__] cult
Dirk with this [__] tell the
Kool-Aid drops [__]
and you're with me here every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific right here
on YouTube so subscribe right now to the
YouTube channel do not forget to hit
subscribe if you're here on YouTube
you're not going to want to miss a
single episode whether I'm here or not
single [__] one
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod and also download every single
episode it's free99 over on Apple
Spotify and Google this show is always
free it doesn't cost you a single nickel
to watch or listen to this show and you
can watch it on Facebook if you want if
you prefer to watch it on Facebook watch
it over there just go follow me at the
Tony Michaels every single weekday you
can watch it over there you you would be
able to watch this on up wire
but that they're still suspended I think
tomorrow is when the suspension's up so
go to the upwire.com or just type in the
up wire on YouTube and go follow them as
well give them the support and I want to
thank everyone over on Twitch we're
getting more and more followers over
there more and more people come and
watch us every single day on Twitch so
follow us on Twitch it's free to follow
us on Twitch as well
again a reminder if you have subscribed
to us with your Amazon Prime account you
have to renew and re-subscribe
every single month and we just had yarg
y-a-r-g yard and re-subscribe for the
fourth month in a row so thank you yard
for re-subscribing just a bit ago and
you guys can go in and you can you can
tie your Amazon Prime account to your
Twitch account and you get one free
subscription with your Amazon Prime
account following us is free on Twitch
that's free but if you want to subscribe
give us monetary Support over on Twitch
the best way to do it is if you have an
Amazon Prime account you get one free
subscription with your Amazon Prime
account with Amazon gaming which is
Twitch
the nice part is you just tie your
Amazon account to your Twitch account
you give us that one free subscription
every single month and we get a couple
bucks
of Amazon's money it's kind of cool it's
kind of cool
oh boy we got a ton of news I got a ton
of Clips I want to show you don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
right after this message
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show got a ton of
Clips to show you today now let's see
where the hell did we start good Lord
there's so many I got Chris Christie
flips I want to show you there's a mic
ENT video and there's Moskowitz
representing Moskowitz absolutely
stuffing the House Republicans in the
trash can mocking them with his
amendments to the no woke stoves Act
holy [__] did you see this yesterday
what a bunch of Jesus what a bunch of
dumb asses couldn't even get the rules
passed on a on their nonsense right and
it's all retribution for the debt deal
that was done
and I I don't know why I don't know why
these these Maga Republicans in the
house are taking out their frustration
of the debt deal on Kevin McCarthy and
other House Republicans right they had
nothing to do with it Hakeem Jeffries is
the one who got the debt deal done right
he was the Speaker of the House for the
day on that one
hey trust me there's not too many times
in American history where you're gonna
see the speaker on the house beg beg and
receive
a [__] at the minority caucus
like what happened with the debt deal
you're not gonna see that you're not
gonna see that and then go on to the
Senate to the presidency you're not
going to see that [__]
it's not gonna happen
it's not how governance Works in this
country with the two-party system and
and how our House of Representative
works but you know under the Republicans
when they're derelict in their Duty and
they're so focused on Hunter Biden's
dick picks and gas stoves and Target
Pride displays and how how gay Bud Light
makes you if you drink it
that that's what happens
that's what happens in this country let
me show you this uh this clip from
Moscow it's [__] fantastic while
we're talking about it I might as well
just go to that club because I got Bill
Barr to show you I got Christy gnome to
show you oh my God this is a busy day so
let's go to Moskowitz here on his
amendments for the no woke stoves act as
I'm calling it I think he called it make
make appliances great again or something
like that no no he had a different name
for it listen obviously we have one not
just one but two gas stove bills so my
second amendment uh would give gas
stoves I think the honor that they
deserved uh you know a stainless steel
six burner double oven in Statuary Hall
uh you know we have uh we have statues
there that I made our marble and bronze
but we don't have anything of stainless
steel and so I think this could be uh
the first one Amendment
so he's totally mogging him of course
this is this is the party that loses
their minds over Confederate statues
right they're like ah you can't take
down our Confederate monuments and blah
blah it's history but they're like oh
the Confederates were Democrats okay so
you don't want to take
statues and monuments of Democrats down
I mean it's it's all confusing for these
people so so when he when he institutes
or when he He suggests an amendment
when he puts more than amendment to
build a [__] statue of a gas stove
that's hilarious let's see what other
hilarion he has in store for us for his
amendments women are three helps ensure
that the hours of hard work uh do not go
by the wayside on this issue and so I
propose creating a position in the U.S
department of energy for the sole
purpose of fighting the war on gas
stoves this amendment would create this
position in the department the Supreme
Allied gas Commander a position that
young boys and girls can one day Aspire
because they're sitting in class maybe
reading a book hopefully a book that
wasn't banned speaking of Allied
commanders there's Gabe sages oh man oh
my God have you watched this clip
it actually in many ways it well
what I'll say is this uh last night I
had this idea to make this commercial
um I know that somebody commented I
should add uh I should I should make a
commercial that has the Sarah Mclaughlin
McLaughlin music behind it right oh yeah
yeah right like
[Music]
exactly that one so that's one that's
one commercial however I had another
idea of a commercial which I cannot say
in the air because if I say it on the
air I guarantee someone will try to take
it from me Edward says hi hey hey Hannah
Hannah all stoves matter I mean oh my
God this oh oh I'm telling you Hannah
this gets much better this clip if you
haven't seen it or or it's called all
stoves matter really and that's ASMR and
that's wow oh man but like I said I do
have this idea for this commercial and I
think it's gonna be [__] amazing
it's gonna have it's gonna have special
effects in there
all I'll say is this if you're part of
my patreon after the show I will give
you a sneak peek into what what I'm
thinking you're gonna do like a are you
gonna do like a live or you're gonna
post something over there no I'm gonna
I'm gonna post something over there it
won't be the video yet but it's an idea
that I started thinking about last night
which I think honestly I like the plug
for the patreon there that's pretty good
well I'm just saying I'm just saying if
you like what was that definitely go
over to patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez
yeah also this commercial that I thought
of last night and I started writing the
script for this morning might be and I
know that a lot of people in the in the
comments are saying they love boycott
binder but this honestly might be my
best commercial idea ever I'm so glad we
brought back boycott binder because
that's an old one when did you do that
that's like two years ago wasn't it
1021. that's crazy I'm just saying I
like any of these things are just super
Evergreen right well I what especially
with these [__] ninco Boop Nazis it's
hilarious it's hilarious that you did
that boycott binder two years ago and
like for weeks we're talking about them
boycott and [__] and I'm like man we
really need to put that commercial back
in rotation and I said it over and over
and then I got it ready for you so you
had it when you guest house thank you by
the way for for taking a note thank you
for today for giving me the reins okay I
just want to say I know that people are
like where's Tony this isn't the same as
Tony look I never said I was Tony no I
was selling in for Tony yeah but that's
what it is all right anyway but I
appreciate everyone that was there and
was saying like they had a good time and
they enjoy the conversations with Dr
Rachel bittickoffer and also Texas Paul
right so I appreciate everyone who came
to the show and didn't immediately leave
because it wasn't the same no no
Michaels we we we prep them to not leave
I was sending direct messages like hey
please go I I appreciate you just stop
I'm just kidding me
it was not it was not it was not Petty
watching they they they did they came
and they watched Gabe Sanchez do the
Tony Michaels podcast and it it it went
over without a hitch I mean other than
other than the typical Gabe Sanchez
entry and without it without his
microphone I mean it wouldn't what the
[__] happened there you know I I mean
what the hell I oh you know I think it
was because the day the day before I had
a zoom call and I had this you switched
your mic I switched my mic and listen I
ripped this guy on Sunday I brought this
guy on Sunday I was like hey let's do a
dry run so you know the the order that
it goes in the beginning because there's
a lot that happens in the background
that people don't right I I actually am
working over here a lot of people think
that you know I just yeah
so it's like right you know the thing I
think that people don't understand or
maybe understand is
um it's just the two of us or sometimes
just the the one of us and we're you
know we might have a guest on so we're
running the board and having a
conversation and while they're talking
being like okay what's next what's gonna
also we're looking at it again how much
is this up you know right yeah we gotta
find this gotta find that gotta get
gotta get a good transition from here to
here which Speaking In transitions
um I don't have one here so let's just
go back to the clip and let's listen to
Moscow it's absolutely barium uh with
mockery here this is I this is like
level 10 mockery it is fantastic watch
what he watch what he wants to call this
bill
we're sitting in class hopefully being
safe they could they could think about
being uh one day the Supreme Allied gas
Commander
now switching over to HR 1615 this
amendment honors uh uh honors this
amendment by also changing its name to
make appliances great again and if you
already have the hats and shirts and
flags and boats so I figured we would
just make it easy
support uh for this amendment and if you
don't like that slogan because that you
know something of four years ago uh we
can my last Amendment uh on my second
amendment on that one changes the name
uh to uh stoves over gun violence act
2020 there were more than 40 million gas
stoves which is only about 10 of the
amount of guns uh that are on the
streets and so uh I I thought that maybe
we could show parents really what our
priority is which is stoves uh over gun
violence and finally Mr chairman memo
number five to H.R 1615 uh to kind of
put us back on the right track is uh
this amendment uh would would take all
the funds that are being used for the
purpose of uh this gas stove thing and
redirect them uh for gun violence
prevention efforts oh oh well maybe we
should do something that matters uh Miss
loveseeks is here my stove my choice I
mean look I'm going to tell you right
now that Biden and the rest of his
[__] regime are not going to step one
foot into my home and steal my gas stove
okay good luck fine good luck fitting
that [__] through my door okay
can you can you believe that this is
going to be their policy platform for
the Republican yes I can you can believe
that yeah 100 you're like oh that's a
great idea let's let's just let's just
go balls deep in the gas stove thing and
then they fail on the house to even pass
the rules like that what happens when
you compromise on how many votes it
takes to get speakership and also then
remove the speaker because you are so
desperate and so pathetic that you have
to compromise on so many different
things I mean wait wait I just got an
idea I just got an idea this is a great
this this will be the 2024 Republican
national conventions tagline
pathetic
yeah and desperate pathetic Republicans
2024 pathetic and desperate speaking a
pathetic and desperate did you see this
clip oh yeah I just want to call out Rob
H he says what's stupid about this I've
seen in many red States Electric
utilities are trying to switch people to
electric stoves and might I add you or
might I add that it's like
95 90 92 I forget what the exact percent
it's over 90 percent over 90 percent of
the uh stove Market in Florida guess
what it is do you think it's gas you
think it's electric I I would I would
say it's probably it's probably electric
you would be correct oh so you're saying
that gas stoves aren't as relevant as
they want them to be other than
commercial applications you know what's
funny about this okay so I grew up in
rural Missouri right we had a [__]
propane tank outside our Farmhouse
literally like a big ass [__] propane
tank and the propane tank ran appliances
it ran our furnace we had a wood stove
too so the furnace didn't run that much
but it also it also was used as a pilot
light on the on the water heater right
right now even in some places where the
the phase of electric wasn't enough to
run like an air conditioner
a range which is it's not really a stove
stove is the top not the the actual oven
right you know it's called the range
um so
but we we had an electric range and an
electric refrigerator and the reason why
is because we had the phased where we
were at in our rural part and on our
farm where we could actually run an air
conditioner a range and a refrigerator
maybe a couple refrigerators and a deep
Resort at the same time in some parts of
this country you can't there's not the
phase of electricity so do you did you
know that there's there's propane
refrigerators did you know that no yeah
there's propane refrigerators I mean I
guess it makes sense like you could
convert one or the other but yeah I
wouldn't the reason why is because like
if you're way out and you don't have the
phase of electricity or you're running
off solar you don't want to run your
[__] whoa whoa hold on are you
telling me that there are areas of the
country that I don't know might benefit
from something called infrastructure
yeah it would it would help it would
help but here's the thing is that is
that these appliances exist because
there is a market for it but if you go
out like on online and you search for
like a gas refrigerator a refrigerator
that runs on gas around is propane or
natural gas you're not going to find too
many of them you're not you're not you
know why do you know why just like
efficient well just what you said about
Florida most most people most people
it's a hell of a lot easier and a hell
of a lot more efficient to plug the
electric refrigerator into the wall same
way with the stove or or a water heater
or a furnace whatever the case may be it
depends on the utilities that you have
access to right I mean some people don't
have access to gas so they wouldn't have
a gas stove like if there's no if
there's no natural gas coming into an
apartment building those people aren't
like well where's my [__] gas stove I
want to get rid of my gay stove I don't
want an electric stove it makes me gay
or whatever they think are they really
going to say that the electric stoves
make them gay because it feels like
that's where this is going look the only
the I would say the only difference
between a gas stove and a gay stove is
one letter well that is true I'm just
saying I'm just saying
it may be easily be made I don't know
that you could say oh yeah but come on
or gay stove you can totally see them
shooting up electric ranges because
they're oh yeah they're they're gay
stoves or they're gonna make you gay if
you cook on electric right I can see
that I can see that 100 I could easily
see them I well here's the thing just
like I had like for the boycott binder
commercial right right obviously it's a
joke however there's a slight
possibility where someone could argue
and I had many people comment this oh
you should trademark that you should
make a website and sell those things be
uh be be aware that somebody from Maga
might try to sell that very same thing
it goes
to their way of thinking that if there's
a majority of people in the comments and
that share and quote the quote tweet the
video that I had
where they're like hey this is totally
believable I could see someone doing
this this looks like a legitimate
commercial even though we know it's a
spoof
we do think that Maga and Republicans
would buy and or use this do you think
it Mega like senior commercial on
Twitter like whoa whoa I mean I need to
call this number get me one of these
yeah 100 they would they would easily go
to totally use boycottbinder.com right
you know they would they would because
come on let's face it the megalodites
are the ones who would print out on an
inkjet printer like who they're
boycotting and keep it in a binder oh so
that way they would have a list and they
would either cross that list out because
remember they boycotted Bud Light when
they had the vaccines right right and
then they boycotted Bud Light this year
because of you know God forbid we want
people part of the lgbtq community
rainbows rainbows rainbows
and freaking out to be like I'm gonna
buy that goddamn can that has Dylan
Mulvaney's face on it like okay to Willy
Wonka yeah it's funny it's uh I've seen
some right Wingers bragging about Modelo
they're like oh modelo's the top selling
beer I'm like you know the
Anheuser-Busch owns that brand they're
like no not in America it's a different
company that mbeb owns I'm like you
people are dumb as dog [__] you are so
stupid there's like three companies that
own all the beers in the entire world
you dumb asses how do you think it's
like they don't even understand how
capitalism works like this fool doesn't
understand how cannibalism works well
listen to this fool this is the governor
she's a [__] Governor she's a
governor and by the way her background
or green screen background's horrible
which is it's kind of weird I just want
to know why does it keep moving I don't
know but it's really weird because they
have the picture of Mount Rushmore on
the side and then it's behind her too so
it's this is a really weird shot but
listen to what she says is the
existential threat which is going to
destroy America destroy America it's
capitalism apparently I guess I'm I
don't know it's dangerous and Steve I'll
tell you I'm like a lot of Americans
love to shop at Target I mean we do but
we just can't anymore and while the rest
of the country is worried about are you
having fun and going out and shopping
and enjoying a store that store is
fundamentally tearing down this country
and what okay so here's here's the cell
that they're gonna try to make next
summer I'm not [__] you folks
they're gonna try to take Bud Light
and Target all the way to next summer
baby yeah we're gonna try to take it all
the way next summer and here's what
their cell is going to be hey we cannot
have a a little small display in a
retail store that we hate to shop at
because let's face it manga is not
targets [__] target audience and no
pun intended but it's not they're not
they're not they're not their target
audience a bunch of [__] you know
toothless rednecks going into Target
that's not their target audience right
no it's just not but listen listen to
think that some rainbows and some
t-shirts that say the word lesbian on
them is tearing down our country at
arita dude just don't go to Target like
I heard this [__] before okay so the
town I live in several years ago they've
never had a strip club in this town they
don't have a casino that years ago
Missouri was gonna try to give away a
license they only have so many way for
casinos they try to get it here they
wouldn't do it because it was going to
bring Crime forget about the jobs it's
going to make crime to the city whatever
and then there was there was all these
uh dark room dildo shops you know what
I'm saying like sex toy shops they shut
them down they wouldn't give them
business license so there's this company
that is a legitimate a legitimate sex
toy store and it's clean it's lit you
know it's I mean there's no they're not
exercising yeah there's no like stains
on things no you wouldn't put a black
light under him whoa what's going on in
here I mean I mean it's it's a it's it's
a it's a professional retail store they
just happen to sell rubber dicks in the
store it just so happens and Luke they
lost their [__] minds for like weeks
weeks and weeks and weeks on end they
were I mean they'd have reporters
standing outside the dick shop they're
like oh there's dillow shop here has
anyone heard that there's dildo shop
here everyone's mad there's dildo shop
here's the address here's where it's at
we're standing right outside the dildo
shop like for weeks and weeks and weeks
I knew one of the guys that worked at
the local TV station and I was talking
to him one night at the bar I said did
you know that your TV station because of
a few people calling and bitching about
the dildo shop up on the Main Street
okay you gave them thousands and
thousands and thousands of dollars of
free advertising he's like what do you
mean I'm like you did for two weeks you
guys did five minutes on the rubber dick
store every night three times a night on
every single newscast
and everyone knew exactly where it was
how do you think so many people went
there I mean I went there I was like oh
there's a there's a whoa there's a
there's a rubber dick I mean do you know
how much money it I mean obviously it it
will uh change based on the region but
like getting a 30 second or a 60 second
spot
[Laughter]
you people but having I'm back for one
goddamn day and here we are talking
about dildos
zero days zero days since last section
yes but uh yeah but it's one of those
it's one of those things where you're
like
you guys
gave them free advertising for the store
so now I mean it's the Streisand Effect
of people like don't go to the dildo
shop and be like oh [__] we have a dildo
shop right exactly all right yeah that
sounds really cool
we've been trying to get on the news for
for weeks now like we've they no one
will let us do it and they're like oh
let me give you a free new segment right
talking about XYZ dildo shop but that's
exactly what she's doing here because
let me tell you how many people give a
[__] about Target having a rainbow
display to
totally [__] I mean maybe target has
inside their you know their executive
office they do have a likening to pride
month and maybe they're not bigots but
it's possible it's possible that they're
just capitulating to the market of the
lgbtq community and their allies and
they're just trying to Virtue signal as
some people calling right I mean that's
possible I don't know I don't know I
don't know if they're a true Ally or if
they're just virtue signaling it's hard
to tell sometimes with these
corporations because their number one
goal is um what's it called money profit
it's money and profit so this
chucklehead here claiming that Target is
destroying the country because they put
out a display of t-shirts with rainbows
on them right that say be kind is a
little is a little [__] weird right
yeah I mean you know but again like
watching that watching that interview
you've got [__] Christy Noam she's
like so uh we gotta talk about the
Target and how the target is is causing
this Mass hysteria and it's going
frantically it's like somebody like it's
like there's an I don't know somebody
with a bit of a twitch or they're like
oh God you know they're holding they're
holding twitch into this
yeah yeah that's what I mean maybe
someone's nervous you've got someone
who's so so [__]
intense on their uh their anti-wokeness
you know bigotry that they're like oh
God we're talking about [__] targets
oh yeah I hate the gays like that's what
I imagine is happening it's like raging
and holding the phone yeah they're like
trying to you know the video quality the
video quality was really [__] on the
gnome on the Christie gnome
um interview but the other the other
news uh [__] quality production that we
have is episode number one of Tucker
Carlson or as we know him Tucker or
Carlson Tucker on Twitter really this is
[__] man oh my God I can't tell you like
I didn't launch the whole thing because
I was like dude you you really are
nothing without your [__] person I
skipped I skipped through sucks and I
was mad at this uh yeah I was like 10
minutes that's all you got but also
it's you know what we talked about
before which is the idea that when you
put a video on YouTube right like it has
to be highly [__] engaging right to
get someone to go past two minutes and
even then you're already struggling so
the idea that he was like I'm gonna put
a 10 minute video on on Twitter which
again look up what the average because
I'm sure this is out there what the
average percentage of a YouTube video
across the board is like a crossover
what's the average length what
percentage do people watch right like
across the board on on Twitter no no on
on YouTube on YouTube because YouTube is
a long form content right and they just
want to know the average watch time
right across the board if if I mean if
if it looks like that exists right it
says okay all right so according to a
recent report the average daily time
spent on YouTube in the US has been
increased over the past few years in
2019 this number clocked in at 39.7
minutes per day now those are gonna be
broken 39 minutes yeah yeah was in 2019
it Rose to 43.7 minutes per Day in 2020
which I can understand basically what
the time was now if you look at uh
that's just so that's that's broken up
right
um
but if you look each YouTube video
duration was somewhere around 50 to 60
percent of the total video length which
obviously depends so that's that's the
watch time yeah yeah but again you're
you're like uh look that sounds really
high to be quite honest yes it's so they
this this one study uh uh analyze 56 000
plus YouTube views across four small yet
effective YouTube channels so again
they're small but they're engaging
ineffective and they found a significant
drop of viewership around the halfway
point in the video and they found it
interesting because the channels that
each
are are each very different from one
another however the watch behavior is
consistent so they were saying oh this
video dropped up 54 62 58 51 so you can
assume
that you're going to lose 50 percent
viewership halfway like halfway through
like boom you already lost 50 to 60 of
your viewers right and that's on a
platform that is designed to watch
longer form content like a 10 minute
video
and the videos that they've sampled
across these 56 000 plus places said uh
you know from one minute average videos
to eight minute average videos but the
watch time is showing you know one
minute 230 217 325 so let's again longer
than the ones that you'd find on Twitter
now so to assume that someone would
watch Tucker Carlson send me a video I
can tell you exactly who watches it is
his his demographic but even then you
already went oh look I got a
notification for this oh what's trending
oh it says [__] Ukraine I [__]
hate Ukraine and they're like click on
that or like oh he's back who's back oh
Chuck Carlson then you come back to the
video and you start all the way back
over right it's this cycle that right
well and the other thing too is the
other thing too is what what Elon has
done and we've been pointing it out and
it's funny because we were pointing it
out
and Elon and Matt Walsh had like a back
and forth in a thread they're like oh
but but see the API it doesn't allow the
views so that's why we changed from
Impressions to views that's why we call
Impressions no you call Impressions
views because you're trying to you're
trying to raise the value of the
platform that you overpaid for it's what
you're trying to do right it would be
like if I don't know somebody
looked at a company that they owned and
said it was actually valued much higher
and that would be called fraud right
there was a person I don't know by the
name of Donald Trump wow we had an
organization who says oh the value of my
buildings and my properties are 50 to
100 greater than what they actually own
when they have to borrow money but when
they act up when they have to pay taxes
they're like oh that thing's a dump that
thing ain't worth the [__] thing
right yeah but that's what that's what
that's what Elon did is we we watched
him in real time like we were discussing
it when they did it like what the [__]
happened because they changed they just
changed the word Impressions to views
they didn't they didn't change the
metric on how they CA they just changed
the word and then they put the metric as
public and the reason why they put the
metric is public is so that it looked
like right Wingers were getting much
more traffic than what they actually are
because they're not actually getting
because what happens is is even if even
if what you're saying is that even if
Elon Musk retweets this and and a
million of his followers
retweet this and and and one person is
is following 10 12 20 30 of those
followers of Elon Musk they're gonna see
that thing in their impressions in their
timeline 30 40 50 maybe even hundreds of
times especially if they're entrenched
in right wing media because they kept
retweeting it Matt Walsh was retweeting
Tucker and then the what what women want
is the other one they keep claiming that
there was a hundred million 150 million
views you are so full of [__] [__]
here's the thing and anyone can go to my
feed and look at it and I'll show it to
you in a minute I have the old app I
didn't update the app so when I look at
it I actually see the three second view
count which is what the view count was
before actually it's not even three
seconds it's at least two seconds it's
just two it's just two I thought it was
three no that's actually uh three
seconds is is Facebook at least two
seconds is on Twitter okay so that's
even less time so so that so the metric
that they're taking is even even less
engaging than on Facebook and they're
counting it as a metric but you also
have to remember that when you go to
Twitter and you scroll through your feed
right right those videos are Auto plain
right they don't have sound but they're
Auto playing so you're getting even if
you were on because it depends on when
you set can't you set the app to
automatically play the sound or does it
automatically mute it and you have to uh
I don't have to opt in you have to opt
in opt-in but like when you go through
so depending on what you're you're and I
think I think you can set it to where it
doesn't even auto play sometimes too
right now where that is you have to opt
out so the thing is like even if you so
like here's I have a old phone that's a
prop phone for Stuff
um yeah okay oh yeah well you know
that's that's the one he calls George
Santos on yeah this is the one I call
yeah yeah anyway on this phone on this
phone
based on what my viewport is right right
where my screen is
when I scroll through right the
viewport's different than on desktop so
it's basically what's in the frame that
I can see and what's in the frame will
activate Whatever video is there right
so if I'm scrolling through if I stop on
something and that's an you know it's an
impression am I viewing it you know it's
if I'm scrolling through these are
Impressions right I don't have to
actually stop it but it doesn't take a
full two seconds to to scroll past a
video right so if I'm if I'm streaming
through I'm like then boom it won't
count but it will count as an impression
because technically wow not an
impression anymore right it is a full-on
view see and that's what they're doing
now let me show you this video we're not
going to play a lot of it because it
really is boring as [__] yeah another
issue I have with the way that uh I'll
I'll pull up my tweet and then yeah sure
replay this yeah yeah okay but let's
play a little bit of this so people can
see how garbage Tucker Carlson is really
horrible at this it's no wonder he was
actually fired at three different
networks the only reason why Tucker
Carlson ever caught on is because he had
a bang-up team for for production on his
8 PM hour on Fox News well you've got to
remember two this is he's doing this out
of his living room now because the
studio he has wait this is his living
room yeah this is another part of his
house because I was wondering what the
[__] is behind is this sword or
something oh it's like a gun rack or is
it fishing poles I don't know no it
could be either but what I will tell you
because is that a napkin or a I mean
it's supposed to be like a you know he's
probably wiping up his tears but I can
tell you I can tell you that this is his
house in Maine the other thing we have
to remember is that he no longer has the
studio in his home that was built in his
garage or whatever but yeah because they
came and just came and they're like look
because it was damn [__] right yeah
they're like we built this we paid for
it we're stripping it down and now
literally the fish stick Prince can
afford some cameras and [__] though
right I don't know
it looks like a decent camera here well
let's see Carlson this morning it looks
like somebody blew up the kokovka dam in
southern Ukraine no someone I wonder who
was right someone did dummy looks like
somebody blew it up yeah I wouldn't why
would Ukraine blow it up because you
wouldn't do it
I would think with all the fish stick
and Putin money that this guy gets that
he could afford a little better
microphone that's all I'm saying
somebody says some people say it looks
like pool cue racks those aren't pool
cute I I don't know what it is
because like those the separation I can
tell you right now pull pull like sticks
have a clip in on the wall there's a bot
there's a base and there's a clip in
part way through the shaft right
but in this these are too wide and
they're three racks so I would assume
for guns and he removed them because he
didn't want to get censored or flagged
for having you know guns I don't know
Regina's onto something here Regina on
YouTube says big black dildo wrecks I
don't know could be could be um but you
notice here Tucker looks really sad
right he looks really sad because he
doesn't have the production staff his
his his [__] show is now
been pushed to talk her on Twitter for a
10 minute 27 second segment he can't do
an hour anymore and the reason why is
because Tucker sucks at this folks
Tucker [__] sucks at this he was
having all this [__] written for him
there was tons of people working to make
sure that he was you know bright and
shiny they had tons of people with
equipment and editing equipment and jump
cuts and all kinds of crazy [__] with
the graphics to make him look good this
is Tucker in his real raw form and it's
boring as [__] Tucker ain't gonna last
five minutes on Twitter but let's let's
let's look at a little more of this
boring ass you know pasty [__] the
rushing wall of water horrible jump
Villages destroyed a critical hydropower
plant and as of tonight puts the largest
nuclear reactor in Europe in danger of
melting down so if this was intentional
it was not a military tactic it was an
act of terrorism the question is who did
it
so it's it's he's trying to be Tucker
from Fox 8 PM NewsHour but he's not it's
it was all it was all a show folks yeah
I don't know if you know that but almost
all 95 of all media I don't care if it's
right wing or you consider mainstream or
liberal almost all of it they're all a
bunch of phonies it's all a performance
it's not really them they're not being
authentic and Tucker clearly was not
being authentic it was all performance
art of his fascist little writers his
little Nazi writers that would write his
scripts every day and he would read them
out of the teleprompter do you think his
wife does his makeup for him now oh my
God I don't know let's let's take a look
let's see I mean he looks look at him he
still looks sad in this I mean he looked
sad before on the uh on the 8 PM hour of
flax news but this is getting pretty
[__] pathetic you know what I mean it
is it really is and what's again what's
with the fast food napkin in his pocket
I don't know what the hell could he not
afford a handkerchief or something just
take it out you don't have to have
something in there you don't have to use
the [__] Wendy's napkin right you put
in your pie it does it looks like a
[__] fast food it does it does look
like they're like a cocktail napkin you
know some somebody's like a few of these
oh excuse me with the average American
Wendy's napkin oh no no I mean I'm only
saying cocktail because maybe because
what it sounds like maybe he you I mean
if he's got a guild look get back to the
dildo right if he's got a dildo rack for
big dildos oh my God in the back oh
what's to say like a few [__] Tails
cocktails napkins you know here's here's
your um here's your take on it
um uh the night that it was released
which was last night right yeah am I
getting this right okay yeah this is I'm
still yesterday like still trying to
catch up 6 p.m Eastern you said Tucker
Carlson just released his first episode
on Twitter he went from having a top
show on Fox with multiple Studios fancy
graphics and the team of employees to
making 10 minute videos in his living
room because this is the truth it's so
pathetic but they're getting the views
all wrong you see the view count here
that's not views that's impression oh no
wait no that is the views this shows The
Impressions right and this no no that's
mine
oh okay those are those are my
Impressions I've had 20 almost 25 000
people scroll scroll past either viewing
it or passing it button okay so let me
just 2.9 let me show the the ear is
goddamn words okay here's the actual
here's a screenshot right of Tucker's
account last night on my phone right
this is his account this is a screenshot
of my phone I didn't edit the screenshot
so people can accuse he's got 7.8
million followers on Twitter I'm not
sure how many of them are real but he's
got 7.8 on his account here right here's
episode one now this was the count that
they were going by now some people you
know once it got up to this amount
they're like oh 20 million views the
problem is
for them I still have the old app on my
phone which shows the actual video view
count the one you were talking about
earlier where if you watch two seconds
of it it counts it here
which
is 5.6 million which is way way less
than 20 million way less I mean we're
almost talking again this is this is
true of a a previous
um a previous one that we saw for the
what is a Woman by Matt right and they
which showed that and that was literally
and forth between Elon and Matt Walsh
right and the difference there was
showing us that there was nearly a
quarter like a quarter of Real views
versus fake views meaning they were you
know
the actual views four times that were
the amount of Impressions which means
that 75 of people are just scrolling
past that [__] right well here's the
thing and folks we should not again this
is a whole don't take the shovel out of
their hands I mean I'm just pointing it
out because I'm a [__] right I don't
care I'm gonna point it out because
you're a [__] idiot you're delusional
at best you're [__] delusional if you
think you got that many views look I'm a
content creator and I can go into back
into my my analytics and the front end
the analytics the public part analytics
no matter what platform you're on
Facebook Tick Tock YouTube they all look
way better on the front end than they do
on the back end and and and the back end
analytics are much not only that but
like so I was curious yesterday I was
like oh I'm gonna I want to look at
something in the back end so on Twitter
you have analytics right now
uh I don't know if you if it's just it's
just me which would be weird or if it's
also
something that they intentionally did
before you could go to analytics and be
like oh what are my tweets my
Impressions my visits mentions followers
all this stuff and isn't there isn't
there some professional um dashboards
that pull a little more out of it yeah
yeah however
which we're going to talk about here in
a second right right you have to have
some you have to have access and or pay
for it assuming that you can get enough
revenue from people paying you to look
at these things on their end but what
I've noticed is that we're six days into
June and I go to the June metrics the
June analytics and uh here I'll even
I'll even pull it up on the screen so
people know that I'm not [__] making
this [__] up
well while you're doing that let me show
this back and forth between Matt Walsh
and Elon Musk on what views are yeah um
because Matt Wallace tweeted this
yesterday he said what was what was the
woman got 175 million views yeah okay
Tucker's first episode and this is where
Tucker comes into the conversation right
because Matt Walsh is trying to draw a
through line between him and him and
Tucker right yeah oh uh Tucker's first
episode has 20 million views in the
first four hours which is [__]
because I just showed you a three hour
after three hours or so uh of a
screenshot from my phone and it only had
five million not 20 of 2 seconds that's
two second views now a percentage of
those probably are people watch the
video right right but a percentage of
them are people who just watched two
three maybe four or five seconds
but he goes on to say we're watching as
Twitter becomes a legitimate platform
not or to not just watch not just short
clips but full monologues shows and even
films which is a joke because it's not
even it's not even a good place to do it
right right someone the other day was
like Tony you're full of [__] and the
reason why because I I actually I screen
share my I or whatever air cast my
Twitter up on my TV I'm like yeah okay
it says every Twitter user there ever
was get the [__] out of here no one's
air casting their [__] video feed
from Twitter up on their TV give me a
[__] break and he goes on to say
absolute Game Changer huge win for free
free speech here's what I want to tell
the audience let them think this yeah
let them think that Twitter is going to
be this place where they're gonna change
Minds because they're getting 175
million views when it's all [__]
it's just delusion it's just Impressions
they're bullshitting themselves which is
exactly where we want them to be next
year right so so Elon chimes in and the
reason why Elon chimes in is because
people are starting to be like no that's
not that's not used [__] those are
Impressions which you I'll show yours
here in a minute yeah
Elon says to Matt Walsh underneath this
view count is actually understated
um
which view count as it does not include
anything from our API for example tweets
you see in Google search results or
Bloomberg terminals now can you tell the
audience what API is and what he's
talking about here because this is this
is code that someone uses to pull a
piece of media from a website to show it
as if it's a native on theirs right yeah
so API is is application programming
interface and so it's basically the way
in which you can connect you've got data
source which is Twitter in this example
and use the API uh to send and use those
data points on your app or website or
whatever so you could have something as
simple as like show me the tweets for
this person right like show me the
number you could Google you could Google
Tony Michael's tweets and it would start
to show you in Google so there's all
these different aspects to API now the
thing that's
so again you've got a database
from Twitter you've got an API that
allows any one third party to connect
and relay that data and display it in
whatever form you want a lot of times
it's to build an app of their own where
it's connected to Twitter right so if
you're building like a a Twitter tool
which is something that you want to sell
to folks as a special tool that has
special little features and presents the
data in a different dashboard but even
even an API could also be as simple as
like you're on YouTube and you say uh I
want to share this via Twitter it'll
open up a Twitter preview right with the
title and the video and you can type and
then boom which a lot of people do what
you should be doing you should be doing
by the way why we're saying that yeah
you're on YouTube right now go share
this on Twitter just hit the share
button and the API will kick in to where
you can actually share it so yeah but
Elon was like oh we're going to charge
developers five thousand dollars per
month you know depending on if you want
full access to the whole thing and then
they're like oh we'll charge you a
hundred dollars if you want like limited
access and we'll charge you nothing if
you want like two or three request uh
actual things right
and so uh for this example
uh his argument about Google search
results
videos and Google search results don't
count because you can't watch them right
you have to go in and then it'll go to
Twitter the API will take it to you
right right it displays a preview but it
doesn't count as a view because the
video isn't playing right because he's
full of [__] he's a liar Matt Walsh is a
liar here too because he replied now
this is all [__] contrived right
they're texting in the background hey
tweet this hey tweet that Matt Walsh
says it doesn't count views if someone
embeds their vehicle on their page right
that's [__] because I know it to be
true I know it if it counts when when
someone embeds a video that I post it
counts those views if I ever if I go out
and I find some obscure video and I uh
embed it from some small account and I
embedded on my account and I get like 10
000 views on mine it shows up on their
view count right yeah that's a [__] and
here's what Elon says he's the owner of
the platform he says correct as if he is
which he's not he's not I'm gonna I'm
gonna explain I'm gonna explain this
really simply the reason that Elon Musk
is wrong goes to the point of what you
said right so if I embed a video now
here well here I'll even bring it out
even further well tell the audience what
because some people don't [__] with
Twitter right tell us what embedding the
video on Twitter is so embedding the
video and you can bet the video on your
website or also but embedding the video
would be if you went to you take the
video link right right so there's two
ways that you could technically embed
the video one is you right click on the
video and it says copy video address
right and then you go to make a tweet
and then you do slash video slash one
that allows that video to look native in
your Tweet it'll say below who's the
original it'll still give credit to
whoever the original Creator was but the
video will be there without their
original profile or their original uh
message that they put on right and
here's why this is important because a
tweet has a URL and the video in the
Tweet has a URL as well that's super
important and the reason it's important
is because you want to have data right
track that tweets those those those
messages right those tweets right right
not just not just the the original tweet
but each tweet that that is embedded in
right because that's why if you ever see
a tweet right you ever see a profile you
know where you'll find a unique
identifier right and that unique
identifier will be a string of numbers
here's a good example here's a good
example so the boycott binder is about
two years old right we just we replayed
the video here on on the show but you
actually went and you and you and I
think Rachel uh Dr Rachel bittickoffer
embedded the video no no I re I I really
uploaded it I remember loaded that
originally the original one is up there
but I re-uploaded the one without the
tick tock
um oh I see I see the one okay yeah well
well I I because I noticed it the other
day when Rachel you could still find it
like you could look right there it's the
original one from two years ago the link
the video has a link and you can embed
that and make it look like it's from
your account other than the tag from
Gabe's account low now you said here
after Elon said correct you said your
counting Impressions is views but you're
pointing it out like hey what you're
you're full of [__] you're right not
only are what you're saying here is all
lies but you're lying by telling people
there's views because it's not views
it's not and folks I want to tell you
this this is a good thing this is their
own [__] smacking them in the face
because as they go along here and as
they buy their own [__] and that's
the right Wing's like oh yeah this is
get is so much so popular it's it's not
yes it's not popular do you want to know
that's a beautiful thing if they're so
delusional to their unpopularity it's
going to help the pro-democracy
Coalition gather up more people against
them and that's what they're really
trying they're trying to get people to
to think that they're popular it's like
in high school these are the [__] in
high school that were really unpopular
and and they got their asses kicked a
lot because they're just jerk offs right
right and they just they're just
jerk-offs and and they're the ones no
one liked no one wanted to hang around
and they're still sour about it Elon
Musk Matt Walsh Ben Shapiro uh Tucker
Carlson they're just mad they're just
mad they're the boys
I'd also say there's probably some of
those people who at one point did peak
in high school and they were like really
cool you know but they're trying to
relive those things uh another so okay
so here's so I'll explain this and then
I saw some people that were asking about
this embed thing and I'll go further
into it yeah sure all right so in here
as you can see right it's down because
cause I didn't really tweet much this
month in the past 28 days I'm I'm
personally down in all these metrics so
I've I've I'm down 40 tweets which uh
basically this is Gabe Sanchez being
very transparent but this is very
transparent right I'm up to 68 000
followers and a 28 day period
congratulations thank you I'm gonna send
him to a hundred folks let's get them to
me let's do it let's do it but let's so
in in the last 28 days right it's a
rolling it's a rolling period so 28 days
so tomorrow it'll be a different 28 days
exactly right so as you look through
here like these metrics are down
whatever I don't really care uh June six
days so far right but there's nothing
here I don't see any tweets I don't see
any photos it doesn't show me any new
followers but it does give you like the
yeah it gives you the however it does
still which is right no new followers in
June however new followers in June right
this is the Twitter analytics yeah this
is the back end this is the internal in
the desktop version in here right you
have haven't tweeted anything this month
I beg to differ I have right we just
haven't tweeted any photos to get
noticed I have
now if I go to May right
my top tweet is actually [__] Dragon
my other my other top mention was
because it was from a what was that
episode where I'm dragging both Donald
Trump and uh George Santos my best
friend how appropriate and then it says
you know in here I've spent 66 tweets
over a 30-day period or you know 30 31
in May uh and then profile visits
mentions and I had 364 uh followers
right and then I go oh there's another
one this is the one between Tucker
Carlson the text message if I go to
April right the next thing is me [__]
Dragon Martial Taylor green and then you
see the same thing actually there's a
couple here and then you know me dragon
Lauren bobert right it's the same thing
as you as you look through that you find
that
there's something broken
with the analytics okay so the idea that
that everything's working fine as it
should is not and everything is fine
like that Meme right exactly and the
reason that Elon is doing this because
he doesn't want you to look at the
actual Analytics
and say oh wait these numbers don't
match up because they're not going to
match up because he says their views but
really their Impressions now the reason
and the last thing I was saying this is
the reason
oh God it's so dumb the reason that
embedding a video does count as a view
right it's the same way if I were to
take a video from Vimeo or YouTube or
[__] Rumble right
and I were to embed that on any other
website it counts as a view because it's
still that video it still has that
because it's not just embedding the
video it's embedding the player as well
because it's different in there you'll
watch the video it'll still count as a
view because if it was not
it would mean that there's two outcomes
one is that that exact video
doesn't get any other additional views
right so let's say that another website
or whatever a very big website or a very
big account was embedding the video that
means that all those thousands or
millions of views never counted which
doesn't make any sense right and the
second thing is that if that were in
fact true where they're saying oh well
these embeds don't work that means that
they're not tracking those things and if
they were tracking that means that every
single embed that you put on Twitter or
an external website or third-party app
would means that they are going to have
to count each of those individual videos
because now they're new videos it
doesn't make any sense because it
doesn't it doesn't it's not real well
and that's the good part is that it's
all [__] and not only that is
they're perpetuating as if it is real so
they're getting boneheads that are gonna
vote in this form and fashion anyways to
believe bone-headed stuff right what
they're trying to do is look popular and
they're not another guy that tries to
look popular and he's not going to be in
is Chris Christie this is Tennessee
holler's clip of this Justin posted it
and and it's you know this is crazy
right okay it's one of those moments
where I actually agree with Chris
Christie well here's the thing is that
you know thinking about this this
morning I'm like this is [__] what a
time to be alive okay any point in
political history where one of the
nominees who is at the top of the list
is
poised to be indicted not just already
in New York possibly in Washington DC
more likely in Georgia and now looking
like it's possibility in Florida
um but then something that uh Texas Paul
and I talked about yesterday was the
fact that Fulton County
has now expanded
their investigation is now working with
other states right so it's possible like
Arizona Michigan where they tried where
they tried to do these fake elector
schemes one I've been saying that for
months that that's really the the catch
that's gonna really hurt him here with
Georgia but here's the thing any other
point in our timeline of reality and
like [__] that [__] makes sense a guy
who's who was a governor who's kind of a
no [__] guy and has good retail
politics because whether you like Chris
Christie or not the reason why he was a
two-term uh Republican governor of New
Jersey is because he's damn good at
retail politics he's really good at it
folks he's really good at it whether you
like him or hate him he's good at it
he's a hell of a lot better than Ron
DeSantis which isn't saying much I mean
Mike Ben's around Los Angeles redo
politics are garbage yeah but anyways
the point is this is at any time in in
reality in real life as we would want it
to be
Chris Christie coming out and punching
on a candidate like this would
absolutely bury them and yesterday when
he did this it fell flat on his [__]
face yeah everyone's like oh Chris
Christie's fat but here's here's what he
said about Trump and Ivanka and Jared
listen let me tell you something
everybody the grift from this family is
breathtaking
it's breathtaking
Jared Kushner and Ivanka Kushner walk
out of the White House and months later
get two billion dollars from the Saudis
two billion dollars from the Saudis
you think it's because he's some kind of
investing genius or do you think it's
because he was sitting next to the
president United States for four years
doing favors for the Saudis
that's your okay so so something makes
you want to like Chris Christie in this
clip right you're like ah [__] this guy
and again his again Chris Christie's
style is a no [__] it's real and
wrong he takes the gloves off he doesn't
give a [__] I told you this was gonna
happen that he's not only is he gonna
just try to destroy Donald Trump but it
fell flat on his face and it's not gonna
work and I told you it would he's gonna
just he's gonna turn he's going to turn
his energy towards Ron DeSantis to try
to be number two that's what he's going
to do and Rhonda Santos is going to get
[__] pummeled by Trump and Christy
and it's not going to be good for Ron to
say it's Chris Christie getting in the
race is really bad for DeSantis not
Trump but let's continue to us agreeing
with Chris Christie and this weird
[__] alternate reality that we live
in your money
that's your money he stole
and gave it to his family you know what
that makes us a Banana Republic a lonely
self-consumed
yeah keep going serving yes
mirror hog
[Laughter]
is not a leader let's give him the
benefit of the doubt let's say Donald
Trump could settle it in 24 hours let me
tell you how he would he'd give Ukraine
to Russia and he said it
he said it on television he said it and
see it and he said look Russia is going
to wind up with Ukraine anyway so what's
the difference
that's how he settled in 24 hours he
calls solinsky and say hey guess what
time to raise the Russian flag up on the
pole we're out of here
he stood on the stage of New Hampshire
and said he was going to balance the
budget in four years
and he left
with the biggest deficit of any
president in American history he said
which is funny because at that time
Chris Christie at that moment that he's
talking about in that moment Chris
Christie was getting covered from Trump
trying to debate prep him to win to
increase the deficit even more and
here's the thing it wasn't until
recently it wasn't until right now
really that Chris Christie is so
critical of Donald Trump and everyone
that was within his his purview but
again like you said during that time in
2020 during covid and when this [__]
super spreader even happened and they're
passing each other coven [__] all
that [__] Chris Christie almost dies
yeah the idea that at that time he's
like oh yeah let me help this guy with
debate prep so he can be the president
for another four years right and then
now he's like oh well you know what he
didn't [__] blower the the he didn't
fix the debt he actually increased the
money that we owe you wanted to be
president again so eight of Wands points
out I'm glad Christie is saying this
[__] yes absolutely and let me tell you
something even though it's falling flat
here's here's the beauty of it okay the
beauty of all these wedges drawn between
Republicans is in the general election
because we're gonna pull all this tape
during the general election there's
going to be ads ads at their ads after
ads are these Republic because let me
tell you something when When Donald
Trump becomes a nominee and Chris
Christie's no longer in the race the
media is going to ask Chris Christie who
do you support and he's going to say the
Republican nominee I support the
Republican nominee and they're gonna
play this [__] and I'm telling you
America is sick of trump anyways they're
[__] tired of him go away Grandpa you
done had your chance you lost but people
are really going to get sick and tired
of these people like Chris Christie who
may stand up to him and then when he
wins they capitulate to him like Bill
Barr I'm going to show you that clip
here soon too but let's let's watch the
rest of this Chris Christie of him
punching him I can't I can't not watch
Chris Christie use Trump as a punching
bag here
he was going to eliminate the national
debt in eight years
he added three trillion dollars to the
national debt in four years and that is
the clip that we will continue to use
that one right there and that one I
think it's it's
there is a uh there's definitely like a
concerted effort weather intentional
happening in the background right like
the enemy of my enemy is my friend
situation but you have to remember that
just last weekend while Ron DeSantis was
again going
on camera while his wife Casey DeSantis
was talking
he said something that's not yeah yeah
he was like oh he totally ate a snot but
he threw that [__] in his his lower lip
yeah he's like
totally normal like a tobacco chew right
but but if you notice there's there's a
cons there's a consistent theme right he
said he would do it in that time he said
he he could do it in the next or in the
first six months of his term
but if he could do it that quickly now
why didn't he do it in the four years he
was president and that's all you got to
say you play the clip of Rhonda santis
you play the [__] a clip of Chris
Christie I highly doubt that [__]
Mike Pence with his very
flaccid ad that he just put out today
I don't know if you watch that oh we're
gonna watch it Renegade here on YouTube
says did he eat his [__] with three
fingers
definitely three-fingered it and yeah he
did he put it down in his bottom lip
yeah he like he like scooped it out
right he's like threw it in his bottom
lip because he couldn't he didn't want
to wipe it on his jacket right but again
that this is gonna be this is going to
be the argument you had four years you
had four years you had you had the house
you had the Senate you could have done
these things you know you had these
administrations you had these people in
power you could have done anything right
get forced through you know obviously
Supreme Court
but when all these other things that
you've now deregulated has come back to
bite Us in the ass
you had the moment to drain the swamp
to [__] clean up the corruption
to fix the debt to fix the budget and
where have you delivered on that promise
at all well
speaking of promises this guy promises
to vote for the Republican nominee but
listen to what he has to say about Trump
who is going to be the Republican
nominee this is [__] great get your
[__] popcorn out folks this one's
delicious based on the facts as the
facts come out I think over time people
will see that this is not a case of the
Department of Justice you know
conducting a Witch Hunt in fact they
approached this very delicately and with
deference to the president and this
would have gone nowhere had the
president just returned the documents
but he jerked him around for a year and
a half and the question is did he
deceive them and if there's okay so so
these are not my words these are
Billboards Trump jerked them around now
the question is and Bill Barr doesn't
allude to this he doesn't go this far
which is kind of pathetic here and the
reason why he's not going this far is
because he knows Trump's going to be the
nominee he knows next summer he's going
to be on the same [__] CBS This
Morning and he's going to have to ask
answer the question of why he's running
for Donald Trump companies say well he's
not Joe Biden I like my I like my prison
it's correct he's not Joe bid he's not a
decent human being like Joe Biden so and
I I'm I'm against decent human beings
but let's listen to what his excuses
here of why Donald Trump is going to be
in trouble because he doesn't go to the
fullest extent here which is that Donald
Trump had intentions for these documents
but he doesn't allude to that but let's
listen there's evidence of that uh I
think people will start to see that this
says more about Trump than it does the
Department of Justice and that is that
he's so egotistical that he has this
pension for for conducting you know
risky Reckless acts to show that he can
sort of get away with it it's part of
asserting his his his ego and he's done
this repeatedly at the expense of all
the people who depend on him to conduct
The public's business in an honorable
way and you know we saw that with both
impeachments and there's no excuse for
what he did here
so basically Bill Barr saying this
[__] he's [__] he's [__] but
does he care no is this a is this a
truth this is five minutes ago really no
[__] is this about Bill Barr uh it's
about kind of everything that's going on
oh I mean it's related it's related it's
I mean it goes to what it goes to what
Bill Barr's name so at the other day I
posted and I don't remember um exactly
which statement it was but it was one
where he was [__] his britches I
said you want to see a caged animal with
a with a filled diaper yeah like
literally this I haven't even read this
yet and that's probably what this is
gonna be
um this is from Grandpa's truth fraud
social camp he says wow this is turning
out to be the greatest and most
vicious instance of election
interference in the history of our
country what okay he's still on this
remember I'm leading the sanctimonious
big in the polls why is polls
capitalized okay but more importantly
I'm leading Biden by a lot which I mean
if you're looking at the polls none of
that [__] is true really yeah I mean you
know whatever again I mean he's I mean
he is obviously on top of Ron right uh
wait he's on top of him what do you mean
dude I mean Oh you mean in the polls
I I thought you I thought you were
saying they were drinking Bud Light and
and cooking with electric ranges it's
quite possible it might be going to
Target I don't know also and perhaps
most importantly they're launching all
of the many fake investigations against
me right smack in the middle of my
campaign no you open your campaign right
smack in the middle of these criminal
investigations you [__] twit he says
something which is unheard of and not
supposed to happen it happens all the
time they they opened investigations
into sitting politicians you dumb
[__] he says doj FBI New York AG
New York D.A Atlanta D.A fascist oh
oh man you can't you can't get any juice
here this guy is in big trouble he knows
it one of the stories this morning uh
gave Sanchez is a why he's in trouble is
that one of his age of his Super PAC
what's this guy's name I've never heard
of this this oh the yeah I heard about
that guy this morning I didn't I didn't
look into him but I saw that he was
under in in indictment no no no he just
made me they opened a grand jury in
Miami okay it's unclear why they had
this grand jury it seems related to the
Jack Smith case so it's it's unclear
whether it's for efficiency or or if
it's a different case that Jack Smith is
now open because he keeps on returning
rocks and there's more crime and more
documents with the pool flooding and
maybe where he's selling documents or
why he had him in the first place what
is motive and what the grift was because
it's all grip for Trump so the documents
he stole as part of the grift I mean
that's the whole idea but Dr Rachel
Coffer says can't wait to find out how
this this do relates to the case again
this is a former Trump Aid former being
the keyword arrives at Miami Courthouse
to appear before a grand jury now this
guy Taylor
budawick is that budwick I guess is that
you say it um he works as a spokesperson
and I think I think he's a spokesperson
of Trump's pack am I correct so it so it
has to do with his pack and and if you
if you're if you start doing like man if
you're like wait a second okay so
so you're saying that it has to do with
Jack Smith right and it's a separate
grand jury and this guy has to do with a
Super PAC which is not related to the
documents or is it or January 6 or is it
I mean what what the [__] is going on
here connected man it feels like there's
more cases opening up against him
because they keep finding crime as they
go along yeah you know Jack Smith is
like oh hey what's under this rock holy
[__] Jesus Christ that's a lot of
Courage that's a lot of crime in the
pool somebody mentions like something in
passing where they're like oh blah blah
blah and Jackson's like I'm sorry what
what was that one sec what was that and
he's like Gabe Sanchez would say what
was that what was that but it really is
I think it really is that where people
mention something offhand thinking it's
probably nothing right or they hear
Whispers or someone alludes to something
without explicitly saying it then they
look into it and they're like oh holy
[__] okay and they start [__] digging
up and pulling the Rocks over and you're
like oh look at all these [__] crimes
right they're like oh let me ask about
this question they're like how do you
know about that and it's like well God
damn that's a lot of crime
Jesus Christ okay so so speaking of
speaking of people who
capitulate the crime
um I can't go without showing
um the uh the campaign ad for the fly
the most
I want to say flaccid and soft of all
campaign ads because I was actually last
night I was like in the bathroom
brushing my teeth before bed and I was
like you know what we really haven't
seen an ad from Mike Pence yet like I'm
gonna I'm gonna I was like I'm confident
this guy's gonna go with uh I'm the
better of the candidates because I won't
talk any sort of insults or [__] about
anyone it's like you open up a package
of saltine crackers and one of them pops
out and like I'm the best one of the
saltine crackers like you really all
look the same yeah I I have less salt on
me okay you're like well that's not a
selling point actually your mouth right
I actually I actually open this to eat
the saltine cracker with the salt on it
I don't want non-salted crackers here
but he's trying to make a case he's
trying to make a case you listen oh yeah
in the Bible that oh yeah yeah but you
listen to this and it it honestly sounds
like a guy who's
maybe like an ad for a radio show where
he's like well you know you used to have
a radio show no I didn't know that what
no okay Mike Pence was a yes he's a
right-wing radio show host before he
became a congressman look that [__] up
oh my God I'm telling you I know all
this [__] I know it all baby it's all
locked up tight up here
Mike Pence was a right-wing talk radio
host and then he became a congressman
and then he became a governor and then
they they acted like Donald Trump's
plane ran out of gas or something in
Indiana to convince him to get the god
candidate Mike Pence so he could talk
about God and [__] as his vice president
it worked and then we get to the fly on
his head and now he's running for
president I was right am I right it says
shortly after his First Congressional
Campaign in 1988 radio host
wrcrcrfm in Rushville Indiana hired
Pence to host a weekly half hour radio
show half hour weekly what a [__] uh
Washington update with Mike Pence and
then in 1992 Pence began hosting a Daily
Show on wrcrcr the Mike Pence show in
addition to a Saturday Show on wnde in
Indianapolis he called himself oh man he
called himself Rush Limbaugh on decaf
since he considered him politically
conservative well not as
and then beginning on April 11 1994
Network Indiana syndicated the Mike
Pence show Statewide with a 9 A.M to
noon slot wow that's uh he ended his
radio show and we had a television show
as well at one point to focus on a 2000
campaign in Congress which he eventually
ran or run right one right yeah yeah he
eventually became a congressman his
brother is a congressman too I don't
know if he knew that his brothers oh
yeah I know about his brother I already
said no I did they hit a radio show or a
TV show yeah and locals
right wing talk radio host
become congressman become governor
become
vice president that's that's what he
does let's let's watch a little bit of
this you think that Tucker Carlson video
was boring
the land of opportunity
Beacon of democracy
I mean unless you're trying to overthrow
it right yeah totally totally am I right
am I right speaking of democracy unless
you want to overthrow it and they want
to hang you am I right am I right
America a land where everyone is cordial
and totally nice or at least that's the
way I imagine it in my dreams hang my
pants gang Mike Pence
what the [__] are you serious okay
number one all right hang Mike Pence
said no Pence voter ever which is like
all of Maga hate this [__] well
who does he think is gonna vote for him
I mother you know he may he may get to
me he may I'm sure I'm sure he's like
uh he's like by making this ad I hope
that I'll convince my mother as well as
mother to vote for me in the primary
where you know he's like but and then
people like uh that there they live in
Indiana that doesn't work and he's like
right well at least I Can Dream It
and when you dreaming in America they
might try to hang you shining City on
the hill
land of the free home of the brave home
of the brave so we so is is he just is
he just gonna quote American documents
and then well I mean this is [__]
quoting uh Churchill so he's like I'm
gonna quote what when did Churchill ever
say the word woke
every time and Churchill was like woken
awoken
let me tell you about this woke ass War
happening right now let me let me do you
know the wokism in the woke of this
country all the way in the Deep I mean
about you but I'm pretty sure Churchill
talked about how ww stood for oh
I see that makes sense now now it's
making sense okay let's see if Mike
because the opposite of woke is fascist
right well that's true that's true let's
see what the Mike Pence says about
wokeism I don't think he actually uses
the word wokeness but let's listen no
keep going here we're not gonna watch
the whole thing just a few more just a
little bit more just a little bit more I
want to give you a taste of this boring
ass pack of saltine crackers the United
States of America
as the son of the Heartland grandson of
an Irish immigrant those aren't just
words my family they are just words
my family's been living I had a great
honor to
understand as governor
and as your vice president
they also tried to hang me yeah at the
Capitol that's pretty sweet is he the
only is he the only vice president is he
the only vice president that they tried
to hang at the Capitol yeah yeah I mean
he's there I can I can only imagine what
the outtakes he's like now even though
people did say they wanted to hang me
and built Gallows to do so I stayed
there with conviction I got an idea I
got an idea for a video okay and and it
needs to be the outtakes
even though people wanted to hang me and
built Gallows to hang me by the neck
I stood I stood proud in that basement
of a building right where Freedom where
freedom and wokeism goes to die and they
tried to hang me on the front lawn what
the [__] okay so here he is here he is
um in his uh walking down the street
um and let's let's see what else he says
here for a couple more seconds and I'll
always be proud of the progress we made
together for a stronger more prosperous
America
but today our country's in a lot of
trouble President Joe Biden and the
radical left have weakened America at
home and abroad what the American dream
is being crushed under running so Joe
Biden's holding up ice cream and it's
America's being crushed crushed by Joe
Biden eating ice cream you you have to
you have to look at you have to look at
this commercial and he goes America is
falling apart why the [__] do you think
that's happening
you know why who do you think was in in
the [__] white house right doing
these things inflation inflation didn't
start oh yeah okay so I remember 2020
and I remember Lumber I don't know if
anyone knows this but during 2020
if you're in construction you know this
Lumber [__] skyrocketed you [__]
Sky everything really skyrocketed really
during 2020 because of the pandemic and
because we had [__] Republicans
derelict in their duty to try to help
the American people they were they were
they were trying to help corporations
and business owners but they weren't
trying to help their [__] workers at
all I mean that that's just the [__]
truth and if you don't like it go back
and look what happened it wasn't it
wasn't [__] Democrats running these
states that were totally out of control
it was [__] Republicans and lumber
was skyrocketing it's called inflation
folks it was skyrocketing guess what
guess when when Lumber skyrocketed
everyone was building everything out of
steel guess what having a steal soon
after that [__] skyrocketed yeah I
mean it's the same reason why when Ben
Shapiro went to Home Depot and bought a
flimsy piece of poplar wood that is the
cheapest of them all I probably my
number in a plastic sack 15 15 bucks
plus per the for the the footage of what
he asked for this is the most
spectacular piece of wood I've ever had
because I don't know my wife won't let
me actually I got some poplar wood I'm
the proud owner of poplar wood he said
crowd owner didn't he yeah he did he
held up that bag it was like oh own the
libs yeah you sure owned this their
their Shapiro and another person who
thinks he's owning the lives right now
is Mike Pence how many people how many
people do you think are excited about
the Mike Pence video
at least three people let me let me let
me give you uh
I mean even with the stoked view count
on Twitter
and you know what I I [__] quote
tweeted that video just to happen out
dude dude's only got 1.3 million views
right that's that's Impressions that's
bad I mean it's pretty boring when you
start off like look I I know that the
the I guarantee if I made a video that
start out the same way you know where
it's like oh look at these fields of
America and this and that people are
gonna [__] drop off they're like I
don't know what the [__] this is right
there's no text on the video I don't see
a face I don't see someone talking you
know it doesn't catch me in the first
few seconds it starts out I kind of
[__] sad with this like somber like
the piano and like this little [__]
hymn music and
you think that this video like oh what
the [__] is that skip like Skip Skip
Skip Skip there's no reason why anyone
would stop to to watch the video unless
they knew what it was right and you see
that video just from the the snapshot or
the preview and you're like is this ad
for like a [__] agriculture company
like is it is it for like [__] who
knows you know Purdue Farms or some [__]
right fly traps is that what this is an
ad for fly traps well let me show you a
video that's got almost a million views
and this is just a clip that acen post
uh on Twitter of congresswoman ballant
here I think is yeah you say it um this
is a [__] spectacular clip way better
than the Mike Pence video tucker video
combined listen to this and one of the
things that you said in your um
information here that you provided was
that the dangers of ESG include
promoting gender transitions for
children and I want to know do you
really believe that garbage it's not
about believing it's a matter of fact oh
oh so so you believe that investing
strategies
are actually
a secret it's weaponized
to support and promote
gender transition for children I just
wanna it is essentially that what you're
saying or do you just use it as another
opportunity to beat up on children
that's exactly what they're doing is
using an asset opportunity I mean
literally this person is testifying in
our Congress as an expert saying that
investment strategies are being used as
a way to make children want to
transition like what the [__] are you
people blathering about what are you
talking about not everything has to do
with genitalia for crying out loud Jesus
Christ stop with your genitalia brain
now this clip gets better this clip gets
better and I'm not sure who this witness
is and really what the what the the
thrust I mean look she's probably look
at her name I'll look her up
um
back it up here no I don't think she
shows her face in this until oh there we
go Miss Guna oh of course it's got the
word gun in it do you think gonna Sakara
do you think she changed her name just
to have the word gun in it yeah probably
yeah well it's gonna Sakara Mandy
gunasakara is a veteran
is this yeah yeah this Manny Manny
gonna Sakara is a veteran climate energy
strategies and Communicator she founded
the energy 45 fund a Jackson Mississippi
fund non-profit educational organ
organization dedicated to informing the
public about recent environmental
economic gains
uh prior to that she served in an EPA
under of course Trump's I wonder where
45 came from right
it just pull that number out of her yeah
you know no reason why no reason why I
asked uh she served as majority Council
for chairman uh in hoffy in Hoff of
during the 114 Congress and for chairman
barasso I don't know these people in the
115 Congress so you know a few
congresses ago
um she led actions and policy
development in the Clean Air climate in
in climate change issues so the question
here is if her expertise let's just say
that it is expertise is in climate why
the [__] are they talking about trans
rights I have I you know that's a good
question again they have genitalia brain
but watch as this goes on this gets a
little better here so do you believe
this
I'm not the one beating up on children
it's the people who are promoting gender
Transitions and children
um that are potentially harming them
well so let me tell you let me tell you
where I was just walk into a Target is
what she said if you missed it there
what what are you like look I understand
that in the month of June there a lot of
targets with and they're seasonal little
corner that's the size of a half of a
living room is gonna have some rainbows
in it it's going to say pride and it's
gonna really really hamper your delegate
sensibility that you have to look at
rainbows and maybe a shirt that says
lesbian on it oh my God how awful but
listen listen listen
chicka after June's over there's gonna
be [__] red white and blue American
flags there you dumb [__] and
not even that not even that it's gonna
happen in June they're going to
introduce that stuff right they're gonna
tear it down and put the put the Patriot
that are they are they gonna be like oh
look Target Target top tail run oh my
God we got him to put Patriots stuff up
they tore down their pride display and
made it I was just I was literally just
I was literally just thinking that at
some point because it's probably gonna
have it halfway through three quarters
the way through because remember what
happens in July on the 4th which is
within the first few days wait wait
what's the Fourth of July what's the
Fourth of July that's this crazy thing
we're a bunch of patrons jerk each other
off okay but what happens what happens
is that how are we doing what wait wait
was that is that what some people do on
the board I mean I like barbecuing go
watch fireworks you're jerking each
other off yeah how do you think those
what do you think those fireworks are ah
damn man yeah dude they got the big
black dude I didn't know this I was
[__] jerking off the fireworks and
then the rubbing and touching each other
we should go instead of doing how many
days since we talked about porn and
dildos or whatever it should be like how
many minutes it should be like minutes
not days but I honestly I I honestly do
think that they probably I would have to
say for the as big as the event is
because they're going to be like napkins
plates Flags t-shirts pants hoodies
[__] sunglasses bandanas underwear
bikinis swim trunks yeah beach towels
you can print the American flag on and
it's gonna be there I don't understand
though how they think this is a national
platform policy that they're going to be
able to get away with like everything
has to do with genitalia all of it all
every single thing that you can think of
has to do with people's genitalia but
watch watch as the congresswoman just
[__] Burns her down wands her up and
throws her in the [__] trash watch
this where I stepped out and this is why
I'm bringing it up I stepped out
to sit down
with parents of trans kids from states
that have come after their kids
and now their kids can't get the level
of care that they deserve and need
and they literally said when you leave
this room could you please the next time
you're in a room with someone bringing
up yet again our children and our
families as some kind of Boogeyman that
you will actually stand up for us and
literally I didn't think it would take
less than a half hour I left that
hearing here I am I didn't know I would
have such an opportunity
but it feels like every single hearing
that I am in whether it is in oversight
or whether it is in budget or whether it
is in a subcommittee somehow
the witnesses find a way to bring in
trans children into whatever
conversation we're trying to have here
because they're obsessed with children's
genitalia uh and I'm gonna we're running
over time and I want to keep gay because
man he's done such a great job this week
so I don't want to knock can I give you
a quick update on this Mandy Guna Sakara
yeah sir what what's going on over there
it looks like and this is from this is
actually may so this is actually recent
okay so may may 2023 it says that Mandy
Guna Sakara a republican candidate on
the primary ballot for the Northern
District Public Service commissioner
post answers questions regarding her
residency challenges in Hinds County
Circuit Court Wednesday in Jackson
Mississippi it turns out I'm good that
she had a residence that she put down
you know like many other people that
we've seen where they're like oh I live
at this one place but I don't really
live in this one place kind of thing and
so the Supreme Court of Mississippi
uh have voted that she is decertified
she can't and they had her as a witness
she can't even register as a a candidate
in the right [__] District Six of the
nine justices unanimously voted to
decertify Guna Sakura and the three just
on the brand yeah chose not to
participate in the decision so no
justice dissented they look at her like
dude you've been lying about the fact
that you lived in this town why is she a
witness in Congress because that's all
they have but again oh my God person
this person is supposed to be her
experience her expertise is in [__]
environmental
um
right but the idea that I'm a rocket
scientist too [__] I mean he worked
trust me the EPA trust me I'll build one
you can get in it and I'll send you to
the [__] moon but it goes to be great
to tell you that her background is in
environmental nothing to do
with [__] trans rights or trans
people or Target or [__] grooming or
this or that no nothing that has to do
with genitalia at all
the woke mind virus and she's got
genitalia brain for sure as they all do
this is not this is all you know it's
part for the course for these [__]
idiots and you know that we're gonna
stay
right with him to tell you the truth I'm
not gonna do you know I I was really
harping on the the mainstream media this
morning because you know this Chris well
I didn't get to it much we didn't this
Christmas yeah Chris licked my balls it
so this morning I was listening to
Morning Joe because I usually do it on
Mondays I usually listen to to Morning
Joe on Mondays but today was my Mondays
kind of right I guess the why I turned
it on because I was trying to get caught
up a little bit and I was reading
Twitter listening and at the very end of
um Morning Joe Joe Scarborough they're
like uh Mika's like Hey Joe what's your
takeaway from today and Joe's like oh
all the [__] going on Chris Christie
[__] trumps former Aid going I mean
there's so much [__] news yeah Mark
Meadows flipping I mean Jesus we didn't
even get to that much
because that's not a surprise but God
damn there's so much news Joe
Scarborough's like well we just want to
wish Chris lick the best of luck he's a
good friend of ours he'll be back Chris
is awesome I'm like see you dumb
[__] man they're all one in the
same man yeah they're not gonna tell you
the [__] that you need to know and the
way you want to hear it they're going to
talk at you not to you but guess what
here on the Tony mingles podcast we
don't talk at you we talk with you to
you you're part of the family rather you
love us or you love to hate us baby two
full hours every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter
and uh twitch you can also watch on
Facebook did you know that you can watch
on Facebook just go to at the Tony
Michaels at the Tony Michaels Monday
we're having connection problems with
Midas Touch so I'm gonna tell everyone
if you watch on Midas Touch Facebook
page come over and follow our page at
the Tony Michaels there too that way if
there's ever a glitch on Facebook
we still get you can still watch us on
Facebook if you want to watch us there
but otherwise again subscribe to the
YouTube channel follow us on Twitter you
can download every single episode it's
free 99 every afternoon that cost you a
single nickel Apple Spotify Google
doesn't cost you a thing
to download us the audio version so go
do that we need to get our audio count
up Everyone likes the video right yeah
well I mean you lose sometimes you lose
context right to the visuals that we put
forth like right now like what are these
visuals the people that are listening if
they're just hearing me laughing unless
they come in at you know two hours and
six minutes into the show you'll see
these things that are happening visually
that really how many minutes is that is
anyone counting how many minutes how
many minutes did we go it's not the days
anymore so we're counting by the minutes
everybody I'm so glad to be back I'm
glad to have you here I'm glad that Gabe
Sanchez held down the ship he did a
wonderful job you guys did a wonderful
job coming and listening as you do every
single weekday two full hours Monday
through Friday noon Eastern lemon
Central nine Pacific until tomorrow
Thursday
you're gonna vote for bonehead of the
week aren't you
until then same time same place on
Thursday
Surfside [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon